who tell me about this say you're on a
plane right the plane's full of cocaine
right it's going down you don't do
cocaine but there's you gotta there's
you there's one and it's all wrestlers
who's the guy that's got to get in there
and [__] the only way to save the
plane is somebody's got to do all the
cocaine who's the guy that could really
[__] party I used to do a lot of
cocaine
oh the I used to call him John Wesley
Hardin you know with John Wesley
hardness supposedly the fastest
Gunslinger of all time
I've never seen anybody in my life and
and this is a compliment yeah to him as
a person and a man
I've never seen anybody that could run
and I'll take Keith Richards all day
long been run with Roddy Piper wow the
hot rod brother he used to wear that
shirt that said he had the best shirt of
all time how much Rod can you take
I said that's just my gimmick I want
that damn shirt all right
how much ride can you dig God boy I
would want that yeah I'd love dude my
God
I would love I mean I would turn the
eight ball into a two-ball four minutes
yeah you have no idea really right
I wrote my book He said
I think
I told the story about the Dominican
Republic wrestling Jack bonano we had a
riot after the billions of the matches
and
uh oh yeah Jacksonville because over
there the wrestling's name unless I'm
the first white guy to go to the islands
man this was rough no [__] what didn't
they like well we did a finish where he
had a sleeper what was his finish hole
right it's not a little guy right and
the referee one dropped my arm right to
right and the bell rang right and they
thought that he won and the guy went to
hand the belt to me I'm laying there
like well brought in all that and they
thought what the [__] and they hit the
ring wow caught ourselves all the way
back
got back there
I'm glad they took in the office they
gave me five grand and gave Roddy Pipers
platoon full of cocaine it took us over
to a whorehouse and dropped us off and
drop you off
he really looked like shimmy Chiefs and
uh Trading Places and the lying around
his mouth
but that Trading Places
wow man he ended up doing stand-up
comedy at the end of his career yeah
listen the most entertaining guy oh he
Demi he's funnier than uh I used when I
inducted him an Hall of Fame
I said uh who's the guy that was
murdered Jenny McCarthy for a while oh
uh Jim Carrey yeah Jim Carrey he
fighting in Jim Carrey wow yeah he was
incredibly funny witty
yeah hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one